love is in the air this valentine's day
many are taking the leap
right here in las vegas the clark county
marriage bureau reports a search in
couples tying the knot this year
8 news now reporter madison cambro has
our story
finally sasha a feel good story as flood
birds flocked to las vegas to get
married on valentine's day from the
little white chapel to right here
at vegas weddings this year alone from
february 11 to february 13 the bureau
issued over 1100 licenses
this is way above what we saw last year
before the pandemic hit
with the amount being just less than 700
as for today on valentine's day the
bureau has issued just under 200
licenses
and marriage chapels all around town are
completely booked
clark county clerk lynn marie goya says
they have been very busy during covet
vegas has always been a great place if
you're doing something at the last
minute or if you want a
small allotment we've always been that
destination so in
some ways we are the perfect place to
get married during coven because
we do have standalone chapels the
marriage license bureau is open from 8
am to midnight
vegas is known for so many things and
the wedding capital of the world is just
one of them
couples are encouraged to register
online at mlic.vegas to decrease their
wait
time and last year 660 couples wed
on valentine's day so it'll be
interesting to see what the numbers are
tonight i have a feeling it's going to
be a lot
higher reporting in las vegas madison
kimbrough 8 news now